In our last lesson, we discussed various psychological disorders and in this
lesson we're going to discuss the treatment of those disorders. Now, the bottom
line is that there many effective treatments for all sorts of psychological
disorders.
>> That's right, and we're going to break this lesson up into three broad areas,
and that includes biological treatments, psychological treatments and combined
treatments. I am going to be discussing the biological treatments. And those
include drug therapy, psychosurgery, and electric and magnetic therapies.
>> And I'll be discussing the psychological therapies. Which include
psychoanalytic therapy, humanistic positive therapy. Behavioral therapy.
Cognitive behavioral therapy, and group therapies.
>> And finally I will be discussing combined therapies. And combined therapies are
when we combine drugs and psychotherapy, integrative therapies, as well as when
we combine mindfulness in psychotherapy. So without further ado let's begin this
last lesson in psychology beginning with the biological treatments. Susan.
>> Alright let's get started.